rock and roll
today's July 2nd tomorrow's July 3rd and
going to be on Nantucket for my annual
gig at Cisco breweries
I just joined the band for a couple of
songs it's a lot of fun but I want to
let you know I'm going to be there in
case you happen to be in Nantucket now
this year we're going to hit a few
rockers
[Music]
the Mr one will hit the stage with the
Mr Wonderful S2 I'm very excited about
it first time it makes a public
appearance I have to cancel my tour
because I couldn't finish the ERC
paperwork in time guys the ERC money is
still available no way yes way go to
wondertrust.com to learn more keeping
people with their money that's music to
my ears